i'll end with one that i see
from particularly chris and michael is
it sounds like without using the word it
sounds like what you all are doing or
trying to understand
god or trying to come up with the model
of god and the reason why i say that is
because with looking at a neuron and
saying okay how can a neuron look around
and have some model and know that it's
embedded in something higher that sounds
to me like well if we apply that to
ourselves and continually do so we would
reach something akin to god and then
chris with the quantum babbling if one
can think of it like that well what is
babbling
i know that maybe you all don't want to
use the word god but for me
what i
i have that many of my peers are
extremely against would be to
philosophize about god or to explicate
god or to take god seriously as not an
old man in the sky with a beard
and so i i see you all as doing
something similar in him
i'm happy to be in your company i'm
extremely lucky
all science um
starts with an act of faith with a very
important act of faith which is that the
world is in some way understandable that
we are not just a bubble in this um you
know random universe that just happens
to you know as a as a total random
string of of of coincidence looks like
it's got laws and then in a tomorrow
somewhere you know while you sleep the
whole thing falls apart and we go back
to a random you know sort of random
distribution of events so
we all there's no proof of any of it of
any of that right we take we have to
take that on faith and that may be for a
scientist that may be the most
destabilizing thing if you can't get
yourself to believe that that that the
world isn't for some weird reason
understandable and amenable at least to
some extent to our logic and probing
then then you can't do science you can't
do any of the things that that we do so
so being uh useful and and hopefully
productive in in what we do starts with
that act of faith that is just
completely to my knowledge it's it's
it's it's an axiom it's not based on any
evidence that you could possibly have so
so i do think that sort of underlies
everything that we do just this idea
that we can in fact squeeze some
understanding out of what's going on
around us
i'd also think you'd be surprised i know
that you said that it doesn't comport
with the traditional definition of god
but it depends on what tradition and how
far back one goes because there are
mystics of let's say christian mystics
and his
muslim mystics or islamic mystics and so
on yeah and obviously then the eastern
end is much more
mystical